Part of the fun in creating a 2D game
is designing the game world and levels.
You can be as creative as you want here,
and
come up with something completely new,
or
take inspiration from an historical
great, an homage to the bit glory days.
Whatever your game world looks like or
how it behaves, for all but
the most basic games you're going to
need a way to define, and save and
restore, level layout and features.
And first, this might be done statically
in code, you just hard code paths and
obstacles, and I'm using powerups.
But eventually you'll find keeping
level data separate from game code,
really simplifies level design and
programming.
It's a good idea to store level data in
simple text files during development.
Whether comma-separated values,
YAML, JSON, XML,
it doesn't really matter as long as
the data is generally human-readable and
you can edit it directly.
It doesn't even have to be text.
An image bitmap is another
flexible way to define levels, and
it's easy to edit with
standard drawing tools.
We'll explore this
more a little later on.
The format you choose will usually be
a function of which parsers are readily
available in your game framework or
programming language of choice.
There will probably be several options,
so
you can pick the one you're
most comfortable with.
For production,
many game developers convert text
format level files to binary.
In part to reduce their size and
sometimes to make the data harder
to reverse engineer or hack.
Even if you don't do this though,
pushing level data into external files
is highly recommended and
makes it much easier to work with.